let's see it happens right now and we
have the ability to go wherever we want
to go
that's a good there's a private jet
gassed up right now at Peterborough
gotta be on an island right like a
remote island yeah but then you got to
start
defend like trying to find your own food
and [__] like that wow do you fish
though right tip tons of fish yeah you
have to learn all that [__] yeah and I
think if it came down to dying or
learning you would learn I might not
y'all would
you put out the episode with the the
freediver guy yet no no when is that one
coming out like two weeks we're going
yeah yeah yeah I think you could
Spearfish because he does that he
spearfishes all the time yeah so Mark
has this episode coming out with a guy
what's his name William truebridge and
this is crazy he like can hold his
breath for like eight minutes he has
he's [__] eight minutes that's crazy
and not just sitting down swimming and
like doing [__] that going to the bottom
of the ocean crazy yeah yeah and then
catching fish and then only eating the
fish yeah so he sustains himself just
with what's he has like kids a wife
whatever and um wow so Mark was breaking
it down to me there was a really cool
thing it's like to tell the thing about
him like sitting in the cave to meditate
this [__] points for this guy literally
like for fun to like clear his brand
he'll go down like 50 meters and go lay
in the bottom of a cave just like
chilling in the Bahamas just like clear
his mind stay focused underwater for
like five or six minutes okay and then
wait wait one time he's laying under
there and all of a sudden he like sees
kind of a flashlight out of the corner
of his eyes and almost a two scuba
divers grab him and start shaking him
because they think he's dead and he
wakes up and goes what the [__] and then
they thought he was dead and he's like
no I'm good I'm chilling and they go oh
sorry and then he swims out but like
he's literally just laying there in the
bottom of the cave in the darkness just
like clearing his brain and I don't know
who should be more scared the scuba
divers see in the body we just found a
dead guy there's kids of them and [__]
yeah or the guy that wakes up and like
in his fear goes and like accidentally
[__] that'd be my concern that you
like spit out all your air because
somebody's [__] yeah but he can lay
in there for like four or five minutes
then just pop out and grab some air from
the scuba divers by the way Lamar
Johnson from Last of Us Toronto he's
from Toronto oh I got that right okay so
so the reason I bring that up is because
we could sustain ourselves on fishing
yeah and there are parts of the world
the Bahamas okay the and then maybe we
have some protection with the island Etc
but there are limitations obviously
you're not going to have medicine you're
not going to have access to food outside
of the fish you're not gonna have access
to but you're not gonna have access to
any of that anyway but no you could like
well it depends depends where you are
and what you have to read because
eventually we're going to run out of
[__] we're going to have to do rates
that's just the reality of the matter so
we need to be close enough to a place
where we can raid yeah you know but I'm
almost like I feel like it's better off
mentally to not even have that as an
option
like if you're constantly thinking like
oh we can go raid this thing we can go
raid this thing mentally it's like it's
like burning the boats like once you get
on an island and you're just chilling
there eating fish all day yep and you
know you're not going to get attacked
but you also know oh I can't just go
raid someone for like pills or raise
someone for whatever the [__] then you
can focus on actually living on the
island so my concern about the island is
hurricane season I was gonna say you got
to think like weather weather patterns
no it's this is really important I'll
take that I'll take that I think you
gotta take your chances those fish will
still be there yeah in the game and I
don't want to give anything away from
the show but like in the game there's
some people that built a uh kind of like
City around
a um it's a it's like an electric Dam
that's not electric but the dam provides
electricity they essentially Dam up a
river and that the hydroelectric damage
the hydroelectric damage yeah thank you
they have that in Tampa okay so it's
like
making your city around a source of
electricity that doesn't require gas
could be super valuable because you're
going to want some [__] electricity
especially if you're going to try to
like Salvage Society you're going to run
out of batteries you're gonna run out of
gas you're going to run out of all these
other things the grids might go down but
that River ain't gonna stop pumping so
why they built those cities in the first
place there of course well also because
I think the trade routes were on on the
river right yeah I guess that's the
question do you want to try to build
around existing infrastructure and try
to like maintain the semblance of
society you had before or just
completely restart I think you've got to
go to a remote place because what
they're always worried about is other
humans
go to an island and at least at the very
least if other people are coming you see
the [__] boat and you can handle it
from but you can't see the boat on the
whole island
like I guess what you could do is like
build some sort of tower structure in
the middle and then one person is always
there and they're always looking at who
could land yeah I don't know I'm just
gonna become a zombie I kind of feel
that everybody's no one's happy
everybody's like every day you're
nervous you're offending for you like
that's no way to live let me just be a
cool zombie [__] nah maybe I get to the
point that I'm one of the big guys and
[__] like that that's fine that's not
even you though that's just your body
again hijacked yeah and having a part of
that situation it don't matter I had
those because then you're gone that's
what that's what I'm saying I don't want
to live like that I think that's stupid
you don't want to you don't want to live
in the fear and the anxiety is what
you're saying and I get that too
everybody you love is going to die then
I think I said this but that the book
that I am Legend was based on is kind of
about that like is it worth living if
you're the only person really left and
everybody else seems dead like what's
the point of going is it worth it and I
kind of like at a certain point no yeah
what Squad are you linking up with
because you got to link up with a squat
that's the thing it's like I would love
you know to develop one I like to make
one but there are advantages obviously
for the island make a squad the Raiders
are coming they might come come
a lot of [__] talking yeah yeah a lot of
[__] it would be good though like nah
I'll be fun to survive with so that'll
be fun that you make a squad and then
people come and just pillage your [__]
and kill all these unless you're
pillaging
[Music]
what about if we do it off of an
aircraft carrier we basically find an
aircraft carrier
there's a lot of Maintenance this wasn't
a movie Water World but it was a tanker
a tanker remember this is a lot of
smokers and [__] I don't know I don't
know how to run it in World War Z and
don't you still need like Israel becomes
uh oh yeah a great Hub yeah good at
security and Cuba too Cuba's nice
nobody's even affected there because
nobody could get in yeah so we could
look for the place that's not affected
and then see what's going on but
eventually people get there I'm just
saying there's got to be a way that we
could like curate a place that's easy to
defend that's easy to defend I mean
these places have to exist already you
got to go buy geography like you got a
couple mountains here you got some water
here and you got a trade route I think
you go back to like original
uh the original like great cities and
towns yeah the reason they were able to
develop is they would defend themselves
yes it's like 90 geography yeah St Louis
like at one point had a huge population
way bigger than it is now but because at
the time it was like one of the great
cities right American cities because it
was on the river you're saying yeah some
of these cities that are like very water
bound might become now can we can it
defend itself that's the question St
Louis can defend itself
in the people but once everyone's gone I
don't know you need a couple mountains
you might need some mountains or you
might need to create that City in the
mountains like on some Machu Picchu [__]
yeah like who's really gonna climb up
there see what's going on it's like such
an investment to get up there but once
you are up there as long as there's
enough [__] to eat and you can build
yourself a little Society bro you can
just go live in the pyramids
and then 100 years goes by your kids are
like Dad what are these and you're like
oh I made them and then you can just
hijack history and then all of a sudden
you just start with a huge Head Start
that's sick actually yeah I think that's
the move it might be the vibe be
addiction about it yeah exactly just
steal it anywhere Last of Us fire
question do they explain that [__]
giant zombie that pops up the bloater
they just uh they say that after a while
if you've been affected for a while
that's what you start to look like yeah
yeah and you're way more dangerous yeah
yeah so you start getting bulletproof
yeah yeah I see that'd be one of them
dudes
it's not you though nice baby
I bet y'all have still haven't finished
yeah it's accurate
for no reason
I think one of the things that the
episode does or the show in general does
really well that a lot of other
post-apocalyptic movies don't is that it
has an element of Hope still and that's
what was so profound about her character
she embraced the fact that she is
potentially the future for this world
and then they capitalized on that and
you know uh Twisted on that yeah now
she's a beast okay